[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
zusammen alles was wichtig ist und
wichtig wird in den nächsten 20 Minuten
Christi natürlich gehört die Fußball-WM
dazu und auch sportlich personelles
Stichwort Oliver Bierhoff und der DFB
sind getrennt eine erste Konsequenz
guten Abend wir schauen uns die Themen
im Überblick an
Lauterbach präsentiert krankenhausreform
bessere medizinische Versorgung der
Patienten und eine leistungsgerechte
Bezahlung der Kliniken sind das Ziel
Ukraine attackiert offenbar russische
Militärbasen Russland droht mit
Gegenmaßnahmen
und nach WM aus dfb-geschäftsführer
Bierhoff geht aber was wird aus
Bundestrainer Flick
[Musik]
seit Jahren schon gibt es eine immer
weiter wachsende Unzufriedenheit im
deutschen Gesundheitssystem Geld
verdienen sei wichtiger geworden als die
Patienten optimal zu versorgen das sagen
Kritiker der Gesundheitsminister will
das jetzt ändern und präsentierte heute
Reformpläne die er als Revolution
bezeichnet im Visier die Fallpauschalen
die wurden vor 20 Jahren eingeführt und
seitdem bekommen die Krankenhäuser für
eine Behandlung einen festen Betrag und
das egal wie aufwendig oder wie
erfolgreich sie war jetzt soll die
Finanzierung neu geregelt werden unter
anderem über sogenannte vorhalte
Leistung wer eine Notaufnahme bereithält
oder das notwendige Personal bekommt das
in jedem Fall bezahlt die Einzelheiten
hat Andrea Maurer
dass sich etwas grundlegend ändern muss
das merken Sie hier auf der
Kinderstation im Klinikum Stuttgart
gerade deutlich im aktuellen System der
Krankenhausfinanzierung ist
Kindermedizin wenig lukrativ weil mehr
Betten und Personal bereitgehalten
werden müssen als in anderen Bereichen
Kinderbereich sehen wir seit Jahren ein
Rückzug und eine reduzierte Bettenzahl
weil es unterfinanziert war so dass in
Phasen mit erhöhter Nachfrage wie wir
sie jetzt durch Atemwegsinfekte und
Häufungen haben dann eben auch sehr
schnell an Grenzen stößt der
Gesundheitsminister verspricht jetzt
nicht weniger als eine Zitat Revolution
die Überwindung des Fallpauschalen
Systems dass er selbst vor knapp 20
Jahren mit eingeführt hat und dass er
heute kritisch sieht damit
dominiert die Ökonomie im
Gesundheitssystem besonders im
krankenhaussystem dahingehend wenn ich
immer das gleiche Geld bekomme für den
Fall dann mache ich gewinnen indem ich
den Zahlen möglichst billig behandelt
somit hat man mit diesem System eine
Tendenz zu billiger sie sehen ein halbes
Jahr hat eine Regierungskommission nun
an der Reform der krankenhausvergütung
gearbeitet unter anderem das
Bereithalten von Personal und Technik
soll vergütet und Krankenhäuser in drei
Versorgungsstufen eingeteilt werden
Häuser nur für die Basisversorgung
wohnortnah und flächendeckend zum
Beispiel für grundlegende chirurgische
Eingriffe oder Notfälle solche für die
Regel und Schwerpunktversorgung und
schließlich die Maximalversorgung durch
Unikliniken
was Lauterbach und die Kommission hier
heute vorgestellt haben ist im Kern ein
großer Aufschlag abgestimmt mit den
Ländern sind die Pläne aber noch nicht
das soll erst am 5 Januar geschehen und
vor allem Länder wie Bayern und
Nordrhein-Westfalen haben schon jetzt
selbstbewusst angekündigt sich gegen
Schnellschüsse aus Berlin zu werden
fünf Jahre setzt Lauterbach an für die
Reform die das deutsche
krankenhaussystem schrittweise umwälzen
soll noch aber ist diese Reform nicht
mehr als ein Vorschlag
grimmelchef Putin hat heute den
Sicherheitsrat seines Landes einberufen
der Grund sind mehrere mutmaßlich
ukrainische Drohnenangriffe auf
russische Militärstützpunkte der jüngste
heute morgen bemerkenswert ist die Ziele
gestern lagen relativ weit im
Landesinneren diese Tatsache könnte eine
neue Phase in diesem Krieg einläuten
sagen Experten Franziska von
thiesenhausen berichtet
es brennt auf dem Flughafen der
südrussischen Stadt kosk nach einem
mutmaßlichen Drohnenangriff steht am
Morgen ein Öltank in Flammen es ist wohl
der dritte Angriff auf einen russischen
Flugplatz innerhalb von zwei Tagen heute
in Kursk gestern meldet Russland
Explosionen auf den
Luftwaffenstützpunkten Engels und ihr
gilevo beide liegen mehr als 500 km von
der ukrainischen Grenze entfernt und von
beiden Stützpunkten starten regelmäßig
strategische langstreckenbombe in
Richtung Ukraine mindestens zwei
Maschinen sollen gestern beschädigt
worden sein ein Vergeltungsschlag
experten gehen davon aus dass solche
aufklärungsdrohnen aus Sowjet Zeiten für
die Angriffe umfunktioniert wurden sie
haben eine Reichweite von bis zu 1000 km
dann bedeutet es natürlich dass jetzt
viele russische militärinstallation
nicht mehr auf Limits sind das heißt
also sie können sich nicht sagen ja wir
sitzen hier in der Tiefe unseres
geschützten Raumes und greifen die
Maschine aus sicherer Distanz an bislang
hat sich die Regierung in Kiew nicht
direkt zu den Attacken geäußert es wäre
das erste Mal dass die Ukraine Ziele so
tief im russischen Inland angreift und
würde Russland vor große
Herausforderungen stellen meinen auch
ukrainische Fachleute
es hat viel aus Russland ist derzeit
nicht in der Lage seinen Luftraum zu
schützen
die neuesten Angriffe zeigen eine
Entwicklung in diesem Krieg deren
Auswirkungen auch Experten noch nicht
voll einschätzen können
bringen wir jetzt Christian sem aus
Moskau in die Sendung Christian fühlt
sich Russland denn bedroht durch diese
Angriffe
ja man nimmt diese Angriffe hier doch
sehr ernst denn sie zeigen dass man
verwundbar ist auf dem eigenen
Territorium und die Angriffe werden
offiziell auch als Terrorakte hier
geführt das zeigt dass man sich eben
doch Sorgen macht über diese Angriffe
und
Wladimir Putin hat sich heute als
Reaktion auf diese Angriffe auch direkt
mit Mitgliedern des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates zusammengeschaltet
dabei wird es sicherlich auch um die
Frage gegangen sein wie es denn sein
kann dass ukrainische Drohnen so weit im
Landesinnere Schaden anrichten können
also das beunruhigt hier doch die
Führung und die Reaktion die weitere ob
seine militärische Reaktion geben wird
das wurde halt nicht bekannt gegeben es
wurden ja heute weitere Angriffe
geflogen im Staatsfernsehen hingegen
wird das Thema eher klein gehalten und
es wird verbalen nicht so stark
draufgehauen wie wir das bei anderen
Themen hier ja schon gewohnt sind danke
nach Moskau Christian sehr Mund über die
Drohnenangriffe auf Russland reden wir
heute auch in ZDF heute live um 19 30 in
der ZDF heute App bzw auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen
27 Mitgliedstaaten hat die EU seit die
Briten gegangen sind Stichwort brexit
andere die würden dagegen gerne
beitreten die konkretesten Perspektiven
haben wohl Albanien Montenegro
nordmazedonien und Serbien die sind
teils schon seit über 10 Jahren
Beitrittskandidaten
Bosnien-Herzegowina und Kosovo arbeiten
daran den Status zu bekommen auf einem
Gipfel in Albanien wird jetzt Bilanz
gezogen und versucht den Westbalkan
weiter weg von Putins Russland
für uns aus Tirana
Tiranas Prachtstraße auf der die
Regierungschefs zum Gipfel fahren ist
geschmückt mit Europas Helden zumindest
aus albanischer Sicht der französische
Philosoph Voltaire und die ehemalige
Bundeskanzlerin
die Albaner sehen in der EU ein
Hoffnungsschimmer doch die dramatische
Korruption im Land verhindert bisher
einen Beitritt
gerade die jungen Menschen sehen ohne
eine EU-Mitgliedschaft keine Zukunft in
Albanien sagte 17-Jährige Erdi er wolle
das Land verlassen
eine Fluchtbewegung aus dem Balkan will
Bundeskanzler Scholz verhindern deshalb
will er den Ländern eine
Beitrittsperspektive in die EU geben
insofern ist es wichtig dass jetzt neuer
Schwung in diese Beratung und Diskussion
gekommen ist und dass wir den Beitritt
dieser Länder schnell organisieren
vor allem auch damit Russland keinen zu
großen Einfluss auf die Region bekommt
die ist seit dem ukrainekrieg wichtiger
für die EU geworden
es macht deutlich dass die Europäische
Union den Westbalkan genauso braucht wie
der westbalkant die Europäische Union
er stört bewusst die Harmonie Serbiens
Regierungschef Vucic wird auf dem Gipfel
scharf beobachtet denn er fliegt auch
eine enge Freundschaft zu Putin Serbien
braucht das russische Gast
wir bleiben Europa freundlich aber wir
müssen auch unsere nationalen Interessen
vertreten ihr müsst euch entscheiden auf
welcher Seite ihr steht auf der Seite
der Demokratien das ist die Europäische
Union eure Freunde und Partner oder
wollt ihr einen anderen Weg wählen
ein wenig Verhalten klatschen sie bei
der Tanzeinlage des Gastgebers Albanien
die Annäherung zwischen der EU und dem
Westbalkan ist ein schwieriger
Balanceakt die Integration des
Westbalkans wird noch viele Jahre dauern
auf diesem Gipfel haben Sie für einen
kurzen Moment von einem großen Europa
geträumt mit dieser Aussicht will die EU
verhindern dass die Länder des
Westbalkans in die Arme der Russen
laufen
Ja oder Nein zur maskenpflicht in Bus
und Bahn immer wieder wird darüber bei
uns diskutiert und jetzt schaffen die
ersten Bundesländer sie ab Begründung
die derzeit stabile
corona-infektionslage keine
maskenpflicht mehr im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr gibt es ab Donnerstag in
Sachsen-Anhalt Bayern zieht am Samstag
nach stattdessen wird das Tragen der
Maske empfohlen Schleswig-Holstein
möchte ab Januar die meisten Pflicht
aufheben andere Bundesländer wollen an
der Regelung erst einmal festhalten
es gibt tausende Betroffene an denen
sich katholische Würdenträger in
Deutschland sexuell vergangen haben
viele dieser Taten liegen inzwischen
Jahrzehnte zurück und so auch die
Leidensgeschichte eines ehemaligen
messdieners aus der Eifel jetzt hat er
vor Gericht geklagt nicht gegen seinen
damaligen Peiniger sondern gegen das
Erzbistum Köln und damit gegen die
Institution Kirche es geht um
Schmerzensgeld in einem Fall der
weitreichende Folgen haben könnte Ralf
Goldmann
Georg mene war Messdiener in dieser
Kirche in der Eifel mehr als sieben
Jahre lang wurde er hier in den 70ern
sexuell missbraucht mindestens 300 mal
von einem katholischen Pfarrer der kann
für seine Taten dir vor seinem Tod
gestanden hat nicht mehr belangt werden
wir reden es hilft davon dass seit 1973
fast täglich wenn ich in der Eifel war
er sich an mir vergangen hat und das was
sie sich praktisch auf Fantasie mäßig in
allen Variationen vorstellen können
passiert das Erzbistum Köln hat Georg
Menne nach dem Vorschlag einer
unabhängigen Kommission bereits mit
25.000 Euro und Therapiekosten
entschädigt doch der 63-Jährige will
mehr klagt vor dem Kölner Landgericht
auf rund 800.000 Euro Schmerzensgeld er
wirft den Bistum vor die Taten des
Pfarrers nicht verhindert zu haben ich
kämpfe sicherlich auch auch für viele
andere Betroffene die ist ja nicht mehr
so schwer haben wie ich Kardinal Wölki
teilte gestern Abend mit sich nicht mehr
auf Verjährung berufen zu wollen das ist
juristisch ohnehin umstritten Georg
Menne könnte jetzt also Rechtsgeschichte
schreiben zum ersten Mal hat ein
Missbrauchsopfer nicht ein Täter als
Person sondern die Kirche als
institutionenhaft genommen und die
Verhandlung hat gezeigt dass er sehr
gute Chancen hat gegen die Kirche gegen
das Erzbistum Köln zu gewinnen mehr als
100.000 € Schmerzensgeld sind möglich
wenn es nicht vorher zu einem Vergleich
kommt wird das Gericht die Höhe des
Schmerzensgeldes festsetzen am Ende
könnte aber der Bundesgerichtshof das
letzte Wort haben in jedem Fall hat das
Urteil im Fall Männer Signalwirkung für
andere ähnliche Verfahren in Deutschland
vor dem Kölner Landgericht hat noch ein
weiterer Prozess begonnen und zwar im
missbrauchskomplex wärmelskirchen dem
Angeklagten werden mehr als 120 Taten
vorgeworfen in 99 Fällen geht es um
sexualisierte Gewalt gegen Kinder der
Mann soll sich im Internet als
Babysitter angeboten und so Kontakt zu
den Familien der Opfer bekommen haben
der 45-Jährige hat alle Taten gestanden
in einem anderen Fall wurde heute das
Urteil gesprochen darum ging es zwei
Jahre lang hatten vier Männer die
Plattform Boys town im Darknet Betrieben
dort konnten 400.000 Nutzer weltweit
Fotos und Videos von missbrauchten
Kindern austauschen bis Ermittler die
Seite im vergangenen April abschalteten
jetzt verurteilten die Richter in
Frankfurt die vier Betreiber zu
Haftstrafen zwischen 7 und 12 Jahren
Peter Wagner
schwerste sexueller Missbrauch von
Kindern und Jugendlichen Grausamkeiten
mit lebenslängen traumatischen Folgen
für die minderjährigen Opfer für diese
Taten und auch die Verbreitung von
Kinderpornographie erhalten die vier
Betreiber der Darknet Plattform Boys
town hohe Haftstrafen zwei davon wegen
erheblicher Rückfall Gefahren zusätzlich
mit anschließender Sicherungsverwahrung
nach komplexen internationalen
Ermittlungen hatten die Behörden 2021
zugegriffen und die Boys town Betreiber
auf frischer tatverlaufenden Computern
ertappt einen davon einen heute
60-Jährigen deutschen in einer Hütte im
Dschungel von Paraguay jeder der im
Darknet Kinderpornografie austauscht
jeder der eine Plattform betreibt muss
wissen und das ist das Signal was heute
auch gesendet wird dass er
strafrechtlich verfolgt wird das Gericht
würdigte den Mut der Opfer die als
Nebenkläger das Ausmaß ihrer Qualen
offenbart hätten stellvertretend für
tausende nicht vermittelnde Kinder die
missbraucht wurden
dennoch kann natürlich auch dieses
Urteil nicht das erlittene Leid der
Opfer wieder gut machen wenngleich
natürlich eine gewisse Genugtuung damit
verbunden ist mit dem Urteil heute ist
das Kapitel boystown nicht beendet die
Ermittlungen zu den 400.000 Nutzern der
Plattform laufen weiter
gestern hatte ein Mann in
Illerkirchberg bei Ulm zwei Schülerinnen
mit einem Messer angegriffen und schwer
verletzt eine 14-Jährige starb im
Krankenhaus jetzt ist gegen den
mutmaßlichen Täter aus Eritrea
Haftbefehl erlassen worden ihm wird Mord
und versuchter Mord vorgeworfen der
27-Jährige schweigt dazu von den
Ermittlern bislang nur so viel es gebe
keine Hinweise auf ein politisches oder
religiöses Motiv jetzt ein eu-vorstoß
zum Schutz der Regenwälder Kakao Palmöl
Soja für diesen Anbau braucht man in den
Tropen oft riesige Flächen die Natur
leidet deswegen und darum will die EU
den Import nur noch erlauben wenn dafür
keine neuen Waldflächen gerodet wurden
das geht sowohl für die Rohstoffe als
auch für Produkte in denen sie enthalten
sind die Bundesregierung machte klar es
sei jetzt wichtig Entwicklungsländer bei
der Umsetzung zu unterstützen
nach Indonesien und zu einem für uns
kaum vorstellbaren neuen Gesetz in dem
mehrheitlich islamischen Land droht bald
Gefängnis wenn man außer ähnlichen Sex
hat oder als Paar unverheiratet
zusammenlebt das Parlament in Jakarta
verabschiedete das Gesetz das ab 2025
bei Verstößen Haftstrafen von 6 Monaten
und mehr vorsieht Ermittlungen gibt es
nach einer Anzeige eines
Familienmitgliedes deshalb dürften
Touristen wohl kaum betroffen sein
wir sind beim Sport erste personelle
Konsequenzen Oliver Bierhoff ist weg aus
dem b-manager und jetzt tja wird gesucht
und vor allem auch viel diskutiert seit
2004 war Oliver Bierhoff beim DFB
beschäftigt nun der äußerst schnelle
Rückzug vier Tage nach dem
enttäuschenden WM aus über die Nachfolge
wird viel spekuliert Fredi Bobic oder
Thomas Hitzlsperger werden unter anderem
genannt aber alles noch sehr sehr vage
die Aufarbeitung der WM Pleite von Kata
führt zu vielen offenen Baustellen beim
Deutschen Fußballbund kurz nach der
unrühmlichen Rückkehr muss der DFB eine
Nachfolger für Direktor Oliver Bierhoff
finden
einige Entscheidungen von denen wir
überzeugt waren haben sich nicht als die
richtigen erwiesen das bedauert niemand
mehr als ich dafür übernehme ich die
Verantwortung ich denke das ist der
richtige Weg ist auch von Oliver weil er
smart und intelligent ist und der DFB an
sich braucht einfach auch Veränderungen
der personelle Veränderungsbedarf könnte
sich womöglich schnell ausweiten
Bundestrainer haben sie fliegt der
morgen zum Report bestellt ist in der
DFB-Zentrale reagiert betroffen meinem
Trainerteam und mir fällt im Moment die
Vorstellung schwer wie die durch Olivers
Ausscheiden entstehende Lücke fachlich
und menschlich geschlossen werden kann
über mögliche Bier auf Nachfolger wird
Alfred spekuliert fest steht heute nur
die 18 Jahre währende und Zeit werde ich
sehr erfolgreiche era Bierhoff hat wie
die nationalmannschaftsreise ein
vorzeitiges Ende gefunden
ja vom Bierhoff Beben im DFB ist sogar
die redefrage an Boris Büchler in
Frankfurt am Main was ist denn mit der
Zukunft des Bundestrainers
also bis zum Bierhoff aus hätte ich
behauptet Hansi Flick bleibt
Bundestrainer aber Flick betont ja heute
in der DFB Presse Mitteilung er sei tief
betroffen Flick verliert ja nicht nur
einen Fachmann sondern auch eine
Vertrauensperson und einen Freund
auffällig ist dass Flick auch heute
seine eigene Zukunft offen gelassen hat
dass birgt natürlich eine gewisse
Brisanz vor der Lagebesprechung morgen
Flick wird garantiert nicht sich
irgendeinen Sportdirektor vor die Nase
setzen lassen sollte Flick jetzt auch
aufhören wäre das der nächste Tiefschlag
für den DFB nach dem Bierhoff aus und
der WM Blamage boah was vielen Dank für
diese Einschätzung nach Frankfurt am
Main als vorletzte Mannschaft ist
Marokko erstmalig ins Viertelfinale bei
einer Weltmeisterschaft eingezogen ja
Marokko die Überraschung dieser entrunde
als letztes verblieben ist Team aus
Afrika durch den überragenden 130 Sieg
im Elfmeterschießen
Spanien auf den Rängen dominieren die
Fans aus Marokko ein Großteil von ihnen
arbeitet und lebt in Doha die Führung
haben als erste die Spanier auf dem Fuß
Asensio Latte spektakulär aber abseits
doch auch Marokko schnuppert noch in der
ersten Halbzeit an der Führung uval auf
agüert zur Pause steht's nur zu Null und
da die Außenseite auch in der zweiten
Hälfte jeden Angriff Spaniens abwehren
feiern ihre Fans das Erreichen der
Verlängerung
und den der hat Marokko die erste große
Chance
Khedira vertan das Elfmeterschießen
rückt immer näher noch eine Top Chance
für sarabia
dann ist es soweit
Busquets tritt als dritter Spanier an
keiner seiner beiden Teamkameraden hat
getroffen
und auch ihr nicht nach einmal posten
die zweite Parade von Bono Hakimi kann
jetzt zum Sieg treffen und wie er das
macht Spanien ausgeschieden Marokko im
Viertelfinale
tja und auf wen Marokko am
Samstagnachmittag nun im Viertelfinale
trifft wird am Abend zwischen Portugal
und der Schweiz entschieden dabei könnte
Portugals Kapitän Cristiano Ronaldo mit
seinem insgesamt 9 WM-Treffer eine
Bestmarke egalisieren
Superstar Cristiano Ronaldo wird sicher
wieder im Mittelpunkt stehen der WM
Torrekord von eosebio ein Ziel dass er
unbedingt noch erreichen will wichtiger
aber könnte Teamkollege Bruno
fernandeschwerden der nach seiner
geldpause wieder dabei ist zwei Spiele
zwei Vorlagen zwei Tore Fernandes
unheimlich effektiv könnte Portugal
gegen die Schweiz ins Viertelfinale
bringen
das wird sicher ein hartes Spiel aber
wir Portugiesen wir glauben an den Sieg
ein Selbstläufer aber wird das nicht die
Schweizer wollen endlich nach 1954
wieder in ein WM-Viertelfinale und das
ist möglich ist haben sie im Juni
gezeigt als die Portugal in der nations
League mit 1 zu 0 bezwingen
erstmal Rocco dann die Schweiz werden
Dinge allerdings Dankeschön Christin zum
Wetter haben wir so viel morgen im
Nordosten neben Sonne auch einige Schnee
und Regenschauer möglich im Südwesten
trocken Details gleich mit Osten terli
das heute journal heute ausnahmsweise
etwas später gegen 23:15 Uhr mit Maria
Slomka ja das war's von uns aus dem
heute 19 Team an diesem Dienstag für Sie
noch einen entspannten Abend und gerne
bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter über Russland hat
sich einen umfangreiches hoch etabliert
das speichert die Kälte bleibt aber noch
auf Abstand und bei uns ist ein Tief
aktiv das bringt von Norden her Kaltluft
aber die ist auch feucht und diese
feuchte Luft die macht sich bei uns mit
Schauern in Form von Regen und Schnee
bemerkbar und das bereits in der
kommende Nacht in der Nordhälfte viele
Wolken mit Regen und Schnee die nach
Südosten ziehen im Südwesten ist es
trocken teilweise bildet sich Nebel aber
sie müssen mit Glätte rechnen denn die
Temperaturen gehen zurück auf Werte um -
eingeraten Schleswig-Holstein -3 Grad
z.B in den Alpen ja und frostfrei
Richtung Nordsee bei drei Grad plus und
morgen im Talverlauf weitere Regen und
Schnee der Richtung Erzgebirge zieht und
sich hier staut ja im Südwesten da
scheint häufiger die Sonne das bei
Temperaturen mit höchsten Werten von 0
bis 6 Grad und die kommenden Tage
weitere Schneeschauer vor allem am
Donnerstag im Norden nach Süden auch mal
Sonnenschein bei -1-5 Grad und danach
wird es spürbar kälter ein schöner Abend